this video is brought to you by
Skillshare an online learning community
for creators with thousands of classes
in design business and more two months
free trial for our viewers there is a
link below more on them in a bit the
King of Jerusalem stood captive in front
of the Sultan next in the Lord of
Carrick bulks in the sweltering July
heat earlier that day a mighty Christian
army had been utterly destroyed by the
arrow of the Muslims as much as they
were by the decaying rays of an Eastern
Sun the Sultan renowned for his
generosity and his kindness towards his
enemies presented the king of Jerusalem
with a most precious gift at least in
that moment a beating cup of ice-cold
water covered in mountain snow the King
accepted the cup and drank from it then
offered it to the Lord of Carrick the
Sultan spoke to the king and said this
damned man did not drink water with my
permission if it had been so he would be
safe the Sultan of Egypt in Syria first
of the iods Victor of Jacobs Ford and
Hatton slowly rose his hands firmly
gripped on the hilt of his sword his
name was Yusuf even Abe now immortal in
history a Salah add-in or Saladin the
righteous of the faith
[Music]
before he became Saladin Yousef I
Bernard was born in 1137 in the castle
of Tikrit north of Baghdad his father I
was a Kurdish soldier and administrator
who was employed by the Seljuk Turks as
many Kurds worth his superhub cavalry
skills at the time the Seljuks occupied
most of modern-day Iraq Iran and parts
of the Middle East that Dominion had
brought some cohesion to the Muslim
communities after a period of disunity
it contributed to their first defeat in
the First Crusade of 1095 to 1099 when
Yusuf was born three Christian states
were thriving in Levant the Kingdom of
Jerusalem the Principality of Antioch
and the county of Tripoli no relation to
the current Libyan capital the Muslim
states and religious sects had been
mainly preoccupied with fighting amongst
themselves rather than the invading
Christians but that was about to change
in 11:46 herbes boss died his name was
zenki and he was a Syrian based regional
governor for the seljuqs
it was Ziggy's conquest of Edessa a
crusader city states that had sparked
the Second Crusade of major Muslim
victory his son and successor nor ad-din
had even higher ambitions why reports of
the Caliph in Baghdad when you can
simply start your own dynasty NORAD din
would become one of Yusuf's mentors and
later an adversary
NORAD in was also one of the first
Muslim rulers to give the jihad and
intellectual and militaristic energy in
other words he started to campaign for a
United Muslim fronts to drive away the
Christians or Franks from the Holy Lands
Noor and in occupied Damascus making it
the seat of his power the great Syrian
city became the capital of his new
dynasty the zengids
as well as a center for religious
studies and propaganda calling for jihad
against the Franks in his teens Yousef
moved to Damascus as an assistant to his
second mentor his uncle Shakur chicle
was a trusted general of nur ad-din a
born warrior a tough guy with a
voracious appetite a huge belly and a
blind eye there was in this environment
that yusuf spent his formative years
learning the art of military and
political leadership from his two
mentors in the early 11th 60s NORAD
didn't and chikuwa
turns their eyes all three of them to
Egypt this wealthy and fertile
and was ruled by a Shia dynasty the
Fatima's and their power was vacillating
it was a great opportunity for the
rulers in Damascus to expands their
territory and get a hold of Egyptian
riches before the Franks in Jerusalem
did the same thing Shakur was the right
man for the job and he delivered with
Saladin as a trusted second in commands
the general took control of Egypt in the
summer of 1169 becoming its minister on
behalf of nur ad-din surely Shakur had
reasons to celebrate but he probably
partied a bit too much because two
months after the conquest the voracious
general died apparently due to
indigestion this tragedy did have a
silver lining for use of thick his
uncle's death meant that he could
succeed in as Minister on paper he was
likely to fail he was an outsider a
Sunni card at the service of a Sunni
Turk administering a land of sheer Arabs
with no real bureaucratic experience to
speak of but in spite of all this
Saladin thrived in his new job the key
to Saladin success was that he
surrounded himself with the right people
he started appointing family members to
key advisory positions or protection
positions around him in order to make
sure that he had an inner circle of
loyal advisors his own father even
became the chief treasurer but Saladin
also appointed complete outsiders based
on their own merits and regardless of
their ethnicity or religious affiliation
with the help of his counsel he
succeeded in boosting Egypt's economy
increasing his personal power and his
prestige slowly but surely Saladin was
following nur ad-din zigzagoon dynasty
the ayah bids
nur ad-din realized what was happening
and summoned him repeatedly to Damascus
this is when Yusuf demonstrated yet
another key talent procrastination
fearing some sort of punishment for his
increasing independence from Damascus
Yousef delayed meeting with his boss for
as long as possible by 1174 nor Adam had
had enough he was going to travel to
Egypt to meet his employee oh and he
would also bring an army on the side
because well you never know how those
end-of-year reviews might turn out but
yusuf was not only a skilled man he was
also a lucky man and just before the
start of a new campaign nur ad-din
of natural causes saladin who had
previously worked as the mayor Minister
of Egypt's could suddenly seek a more
prominent job title
before the calendars could flip to 1175
Saladin had captured Damascus and was
formally recognized by his nominal boss
the Caliph of Baghdad as the Sultan of
Egypt in Syria in the late 11 70s and
early 11 80s Saladin expanded and
consolidated his power by both military
and diplomatic means his I bet dynasty
it became a reality Saladin fought and
defeated several rebellious local
leaders who did not view him as newer
Adan's true successor with the toughest
cookie being nor ad-din son Saladin laid
siege to Aleppo and defeated him in 1183
but that wasn't the end of it if riches
were measured zin headaches and thorns
in your side Saladin may have been the
wealthiest man in the world as a Sunni
leader Saladin had to compete with the
stubborn resistance from sheer factions
in his new territories which took the
form of assassination attempts from well
the assassins or more correctly that the
dawn of the Nazari Shia sect by the way
we also have a video about their founder
Hassan Simba you should check out that
video as well I don't see done with this
one of course Saladin also had to keep a
bay the seljuq turks his former
overlords from whom he had broken away
in the diplomatic masterstroke the
Sultan signed a defensive treaty with
the Byzantine Empire against the Turks
which allowed him to concentrate on
other matters one of these matters was
finding a suitable wife which is rarely
a benign decision for a monarch yusuf
married a nobleman called is smart who
happened to be nur ad-din widow I'm sure
these who loved each other to bits but
it's undeniable that the match was
extremely convenient for Saladin it's
matt who is also the daughter of a
previous governor of Damascus so this
move ensured that Saladin be associated
with two ruling dynasties enhancing his
prestige Saladin also had another matter
pressing at him what could be done about
the Christian kingdoms he had continued
nur ad-din Zephyrs to rally the Sunni
community arounds the common goal of
chasing the Christians away from the
Levant especially from Jerusalem one of
the holiest cities in Muslim worship
until this point the idea of a holy war
against the West hood served as a handy
prop to unify his dominions
and now it was time to deliver but
before we get into that delivery I want
to deliver a great deal to you and
that's two months of Skillshare for free
using our link below skill sure is an
online learning community for creators
and they've got thousands of classes in
design business and much more unlike
some websites where you got to pay for
individual courses which can get
expensive if you love learning with a
premium membership from Skillshare you
get unlimited access so you can take as
many classes as you want I've recently
taken a course on better email
management my inbox was getting wildly
out of control and I didn't really know
how to tackle it it was one of those
procrastination things so I went on
Skillshare I found something to sort me
out and now I have an actual system in
place rather than the utter train wreck
that I had before the course is called
email productivity works smarter with
your inbox it's by someone called
Alexandre Samuel I recommend checking it
out anyway join more than 7 million
creators learning with skill share learn
a long wisdom in groups and get two
months for free through the link below
and let's go back to today's video
[Music]
back in 1170 for Jerusalem's King Maric
had died and he was succeeded by his son
Baldwin the fourth Baldwin was a frail
inexperienced teenager
sadly afflicted by leprosy the boy
became known as the leper king and his
perceived lack of leadership led
everybody in the levonne's to
underestimate him by November 11 77
Saladin thought the time was ripe to
pluck Jerusalem from Baldwin's sickly
hands he assembled an army of 27,000 men
moved north from Egypt confidence in an
easy victory
but Saladin had underestimated his enemy
Baldwin gave commands of an army to
French noblemen arenal de Leon an
experienced military leader then the two
led a small force to Ascalon south of
Jerusalem to intercept Saladin's and
march the Egyptian army encircled the
Christians but did not engage with them
Saladin gave orders instead of March
further north and loot three villages
before reaching Jerusalem for a renowned
general Saladin had made two huge
tactical mistakes first he had not
engaged when he was in a position of
strength he had also allowed his larger
army to disperse in enemy territory
Reynolds and Baldwin they escaped the
encirclement and raced northwards the
Christians attacks as Mons gazelles near
Rambler on the 25th of November
Saladin's numerical advantage had been
neutralized as much of his forces were
still dispersed and his elite cavalry
was exhausted from the long track from
Egypt the Christian Knights they charged
the center of Saladin's formation they
were spearheaded by 80 Templars one of
whom was the Bishop of Bethlehem
carrying a piece of the true cross the
victory was total Saladin's Center
crumbled under the charge Warren Osman
seized the supply train of the Egyptians
Saladin himself narrowly escaped capture
by riding on a racing camel this defeat
had taught a harsh lesson to the Sultan
Saladin would now focus on further
strengthening his Souls honors and his
army before attempting conquest again in
the meantime the franks had grown in
confidence and baldwin went on to
provoke Saladin by building a castle
that Jacobs forge within reach of
Damascus from there the Christian
Knights could easily launch raids
against the Syrian capital Saladin was
fighting rebels in northern Syria and
could not attack when the kharsa
fortifications were still weak he tried
to bribe baldwin offering a hundred
thousand
denars if he abandoned the construction
project but the teenage king refused the
offer and by April his castle had opened
for business now Saladin needed a
victory to restore credibility after
Mattias art after quelling the rebellion
in the north he assembled his forces and
launched a siege on August the 24th 1178
Saladin knew that he had to act quickly
he had received news that Baldwin was
leading a relief army towards the castle
the Sultan ordered for the walls to be
targeted by a constant daily of arrows
to weaken the frank garrison at the same
time a contingent of expert Syrian
miners had started to SAP the walls of
the northeastern corner this
concentrated action rapidly dug deep
pits under the ramparts which were then
set on fire
the mighty 10-meter walls were weakened
by the heat and finally they collapsed
the ibid army poured through the breach
and massacred 800 of the defenders
Saladin also captured 700 prisoners and
tons of loot including a thousand suits
of armor the castle had fallen after
only five days in 1180 Saladin and
Baldwin the 4th they agreed to a truce
whereby the Crusader kingdoms and the
iobit territories which coexist in peace
for two years but that truce would never
be carried out Renard
aheh Tilian Baldwin's European allies
rolled over to powerful strongholds the
Krakens Montreal which gave him control
over routes used by Muslim traders and
pilgrims going to Mecca in the summer of
Italian plundered one of these caravans
Saladin asked for the loot to be returns
but as the arrogance Lord refused
causing hostilities to resume both on
land and at sea
Rana launched a fleet of 5 galleys in
the Red Sea attacking merchant ships
raiding Muslim ports and even
threatening Mecca Saladin zone Egyptian
fleet destroyed the Raiders but the
Sultan was not as successful on lands
the attempted to seize the correct twice
an 1183 and 1184 and twice the let the
king came to the rescue of Rinna the
following year though the young sickly
king he died childless leaving his
throne to his 8 year old nephew Baldwin
v the boys tutored the count of Tripoli
negotiated another truce with Saladin it
was a wise move because the leadership
in Jerusalem was about to become a
rather messy one year later in 1186 the
boy King Baldwin v died as did his
father the
Millia remarried a French nobleman a guy
named well G of listen your and here at
in your enters the picture again this he
ensured that he be named King Regents of
Jerusalem
next the untamable Renauld did what he
was best at breaking truces and raiding
Muslim caravans but the one he plundered
in 1186 was not just any Caravan
according to some contemporary sources
Saladin sister was travelling in it
although this claim is disputed in any
case it was yet another provocation King
G astronauts who returned the loot and
the prisoners to Saladin but the
stubborn Lord refused up to that point
Saladin had taken advantage of the
truces with the Christians to completes
the conquest of Mosul which is
modern-day Iraq from a rival Sunni
leader with muscle under his control the
Sultan have completed the consolidation
of his reign enveloping Jerusalem
Tripoli and Antioch
now the Sultan who is ready to launch an
all-out attack on the Franks
he would not allow this last provocation
to go unpunished
[Music]
the Sultan of Egypt in Syria was ready
for his greatest feat yet it was time to
reclaim Jerusalem his eldest son hour
after hour quickly recruited twenty four
thousand troops and in the summer of
1187 Saladin made his first move the
capture of Tiberias on the Sea of
Galilee gear the senior did not respond
to the provocation but his councilors
including liliane and the Knights
Templar insisted that he act lest he
lose his fragile grip on the throne so
at the behest of his European allies
gi's sent 1300 knights and 18,000
soldiers on a track of 32 kilometers
from Jerusalem to Tiberias this was an
endless march under the ruthless July
Sun of the Levant across an arid plateau
with all water supplies cut from them by
the EU bits ghee had fallen into
Saladin's trap the journey to Tiberius
was a living nightmare for the Franks
Saladin's mounted archers targeted them
with a constant rain of arrows according
to contemporary writer Ahmad add-in the
arrows plunged into them transforming
their lions into hedgehogs
by the 3rd of July the Frank army had
set up a camp for the night near the
village of Hatton and got some respite
but short-lived on the morning of the
4th Saladin had ordered his men to set
fire to the surrounding grass and brush
tricking Christians and making their
thirst even worse as a further rain of
arrows descended upon them the Christian
infantry scattered out of formation the
Templar and hospital and knights tried
to consecutive desperate charges against
the iobit center in a repeat of Mont
kazar but Saladin was ready and had his
own riders encircle and Massacre the
Crusaders by the ends of the Battle of
Hattin the mighty Christian army had
been crushed
thousands lay dead many more were
captured and sold into slavery
the Templars and knight sauce polluters
who had been so unlucky to fall
prisoners to the eye beds worth the
headed one after the other in a
relentless display of butchery the
holiest of the relics the true cross had
fallen into the Muslims hands it was
after a Hatton that Saladin met with the
commanders of the Franks key of licinia
and the despised Renault of haughty Leon
Saladin offered a cup of icy water to
gay who then passed it to Renault
Saladin turns the king and he spoke this
damned man did not drink water with my
permission if it had
and so he would be safe this was a clear
threat if the Sultan had offered the
water directly to Rennell the Lord of
Carrick would have been under his
protection according to the customs of
hospitality but this was not the case
Saladin rose unsheathed is sword and
with his own hand he cut off Italians
head
the Sultan then reassure loosen your it
is not the whomps of Kings to kill Kings
but that man had transgressed all bounds
in an act of chivalric generosity which
many described as typical of the Sultan
Saladin freed key on one condition to
promise he would never again take up
arms against the Muslims the news of the
defeat it soon reached Western Europe
the true cross had been lost the frank
army was decimated and Jerusalem was now
vulnerable Saladin moved on to beseech
the holy city defended by the French
noblemen burial of Evelyn after Hatton
Balian had fled to Jerusalem to reunite
with his wife in order to cross the eye
of eight lines he had promised to
Saladin that he would not fight the
Muslims anymore
as soon as he reached Jerusalem Queen
Isabella asked him to lead the defense
of the city which he reluctantly agreed
to pass Saladin's army approached
Jerusalem Balian
sent him an n-by-n forming him of his
decision since hatun loosing yuan had
already broken his promise and now bali
on the sultan was furious on September
the 20th 1187 the Egyptian and Syrian
army captain site of the city walls in
spite of his anger the sultan tried to
find a diplomatic resolution but the
talks were fruitless and a siege ensued
throughout September valiant was able to
repel the Sultan's attempts to storm the
city walls or tear them down with manga
novels and catapults there was only at
the end of the month that Saladin
applied his experience from Jacobs port
his sappers weakened a section of the
walls near the Mount of Olives which
collapsed on the 29th of September even
still the ibid army could not force
their way through the breach which
allowed for further talks and a peaceful
transition for the city Balian
negotiated for 7,000 citizens not to be
sold into slavery against a ransom of
30,000 Zant's Saladin agreed and in an
act of generosity later persuaded his
officers to free without ransom most of
their captives the remaining Western
inhabitants left Jerusalem while the
Eastern Christians were permitted
remain Saladin had all churches
converted into mosques except for the
Church of the Holy Sepulchre all
Christian pilgrims would be granted safe
passage from then on a decision which
should have prevented further conflicts
with the European kingdoms Saladin had
won Jerusalem back for his kingdom and
he had done so with minimal Christian
bloodshed his conflicts with the
Europeans it should have ended there
unfortunately his plan of peace didn't
quite work after hearing of the capture
of Jerusalem Pope Gregory the third
allegedly was so shocked that he died of
a heart attack he had just enough breath
left in his lungs to call for a holy war
[Music]
at the time of Saladin's great jerusalem
conquest there were three great monarchs
on the european continent
frederick the first of the Holy Roman
Empire known as Barbarossa for the
second or Gustus of France and the
English King Richard the first the
Lionheart
all three rallied around the new Pope
Clement the 3rd and raised a new
collective Crusader army together they
undertook the Third Crusade on his way
to the Holy Land Barbarossa was stalled
by the Byzantine Empire still tied to
Saladin by their previous alliance
Frederick pressed on only to drown in a
river in Cilicia wrong June the 10th
1190 ironically had taken the land route
due to his fear of drowning in the sea
his army the strongest of the Crusader
forces it was scattered and returned to
Germany exactly one year later Philip
and Richard finally arrived in the
Levant and took part in the major battle
against Saladin's forces the siege of
acre a major ivett garrison thanks to
Kiev listen.you on the city had been
since August of 1189 but he soon found
himself surrounded by more eyelid troops
siege within a siege Richard the
Lionheart soon proved to be a perfect
match for Saladin's military skills he
could bring to the table a sound
strategic mind effective siege engines
and tons of cash on his way to acre
which it had conquered Cyprus from the
Byzantines and then sold it to the
Templars this sweet deal in real estate
allowed him to pay for additional
sappers that brought down acres walls
the city was captured on July the 12th
alongside the bulk of Saladin's Navy
Richard offered to return more than
2,000 prisoners to Saladin for a ransom
but the Sultan's drawn-out negotiations
exasperated the English king leading to
their mass execution soon philip ii had
to abandon the crusade to deal with
threats to his throne back home
richard was now numerically inferior
against the arvid's but his campaign
would still benefit from a more unified
leadership structure on the other side
of the battle Saladin seemed to have
lost his touch maybe the Sultan in
general as well as his armies were
simply exhausted after years of
incessant campaigning against Christian
kingdoms and Muslim rebels it has been
speculated that Saladin had been ill for
several years as he began to show
symptoms comparable to those of
irritable bowel syndrome
whatever the reasons for this decline he
could not stop the march of the Crusader
King from acre down to Jerusalem Saladin
tried to replicate the success of Hattin
first by harassing Richards column with
hordes of mounted archers then by
engaging in a pitch battle at a serf on
September the 7th 1191 but Richard was
not loosen yawn he had ensured one flank
of his army was protected by the
coastline avoiding encirclement he
understood the concept of logistics
meaning as soldiers were unlikely to die
of thirst Saladin did not suffer heavy
losses but the stalemate forced him to
withdraw Richard's army then took Jaffa
where they rested until January 11 92
the Lionheart was within reach of
Jerusalem by now but he hesitated to
attack he believed he could take the
city but he was certain his army could
not sustain a counter-attack
the Crusaders basically did nothing for
six months as did Saladin another sign
of his waning decisiveness only in July
did Saladin reconquer Jaffa but lost it
again to the Lionheart in August this
would be the last time the two bleeders
would face each other in battle when I
say face each other I don't mean
literally a number of legends and
popular novels depicted Saladin and
Richard as best frenemies who remained
respectful of each other while engaging
in battles and even personal duels in
fact though the two never met in person
even after Jaffa when the two sides
engaged in length of the negotiations
these were always carried out by in
voice Richard did develop a liking for
salad in at a distance and it is mainly
thanks to him that Europeans learned to
appreciate the Sultan as a fair ruler
and combatant embodying the ideals of
perfect chivalry
Richard even considered having his
sister Johanna engaged to Saladin's
brother the results of the negotiations
or not in marriage but a peace deal that
was agreeable to both sides Richard had
fallen ill and was itching to return to
England where his brother John was
conspiring with Philip of France to
strip of his lands Saladin was only too
eager to get rid of the Lionheart and
gave important concessions the Crusaders
would retain a strip of land around acre
and he would ensure safe passage for all
Christian pilgrims going to Jerusalem in
their last exchange of letters Richard
wrote to Saladin that sooner or later he
would return and conquer the Holy Land
for good the Sultan replied accepting
the challenge and writing that if he had
to lose his empire to and
the king he could not think of a better
one
[Music]
the Third Crusade was over by October
1192 Richard had scored a number of
tactical victories but in the end
Saladin had the upper hand strategically
speaking his Sultanate was still intact
would Saladin have ever expanded his
territories beyond their boundaries at
the end of the Third Crusade we don't
know as Yusuf Eibon ayob died five
months later on the 4th of March 1193
maybe it was irritable bowel syndrome or
perhaps it was just sheer exhaustion
from constant war that the coalition he
had built quickly disintegrated as three
of Saladin's sons took control of Egypt
Damascus and Aleppo other relatives and
subordinates called for the remainders
the either dynasty ruled until 1260 when
it was overthrown by an emerging power
in Egypt and Mamluks despite spending
much of its time fighting fellow Muslims
instead of Christians Saladin is
remembered in modern times as the great
adversary of the Crusaders he was a
valiant fair and generous military
leader one who did not shy away from
bloodshed or even prisoner execution but
one whose conduct in Jerusalem was
nonetheless exemplary in spite of the
occasional tactical blunder Saladin
eventually achieved all of his strategic
goals his empire may have crumbled in a
span of a few decades but this may have
ultimately been his life's major
achievement to be remembered as a hero
both by Islam and Christianity so I
really hope you found that video
interesting if you did please do smash
that thumbs up button below and do not
forget to subscribe also check out our
fantastic sponsor skill share link below
and thank you for watching
[Music]